The house system is here to make
whatever you want to do at Harvard possible.
There are 12 residential Harvard houses.
[ Female Student ] Each house has
its own dining hall, its own community...
its own population of students.
After freshman year, you are randomly
sorted into one of those houses.
Not only is the house a center
for non-classroom learning...
but it’s also a hub for social activity.
[ Female Student #2 ]
You all live together and eat together...
and participate in events together.
[ Female Student #3 ]
There are people from every country...
every religion,
and that’s where you really learn.
A lot of the opportunities that you have...
to have those
close one-on-one conversations...
with a professor, with someone
who’s visiting from another university–
The place where you really get to engage
with those people is in your house.
[ Man ] Our job’s really
to try and help this house...
be as vibrant and intellectual
and fun as possible.
[ Lowell Housemaster ] Lowell House
is a place that has a lot of traditions...
like having tea on Thursdays at 5:00.
- [ Female Student #4 ]
There’s an opera every year.
- [ Male Student ] Dances in the house.
It’s a good time to get to know
other people in the house...
to see your friends,
catch up on the week.
It’s a place where you can be who you are
and discover who you want to become.
I think coming back home
is a very comfortable space.
[ Lowell Housemaster ] This is really an attempt
to create a community within a college.
This is what makes a Harvard education
very distinctive.